fête des pompiers
[Musique]
merci m 5
certains disent que c'est l'uniforme
d'autres admirent leur courage
quoi qu'il en soit côté séduction les
pompiers n'ont pas trop de soucis à se
faire et pendant les bals du 14 juillet
le mythe de l'homme des casernes est à
son paroxysme les pompiers français sont
magnifiques
beaucoup plus que les américains fassent
attendent enthousiasme pourquoi ne pas
en profiter
certains ne se font pas prier vraiment
dragueur serait très bon premier oui
mais pour le prétendu mais modérément
yama comique et derrière dans mon corps
et quand l'uniforme ne suffit pas à
convaincre les demoiselles les pompiers
abattent leurs dernières cartes
le strip tease c'était le clou du
spectacle le strip tease des pompiers
qui marque le grand retour des soldats
du feu pour la fête nationale
[Applaudissements]
quarante ans plus tôt en 1975 ce pompier
faisait déjà tombé l'uniforme des
muscles il en avait à revendre au point
d'en faire une spécialité
gérard but nous n'est pas un sapeur
pompier comme les autres sacrifices
persévérance qui ont valu d'être un peu
la gloire de ses collègues pompiers en
tout cas de devenir un monsieur muscle
un champion de culturisme
mais vous pensez que que les que les
femmes enfin les dames aiment le
culturisme vire les home games bataille
certainement autre femme ma femme
pour d'autres le mythe de l'homme du feu
doit aussi servir la bonne cause
en 2000 dans la drôme des pompiers
volontaires donné de leur personne au
profit de l'association des paralysés de
france
ils ont décidé de poser nue pour le
calendrier de 2001
[Musique]